Now, all right, welcome everybody to another Zoom call to June.
So hopefully I was going to put some pictures of your garden up so you could see that.
And of course, I forgot. So maybe next time, I encourage you guys to get out and
get some fresh air gardening just because it's our hobby doesn't mean it has to be yours.
So remember, when you do your cheek swabs or your request to coaching call, please fill out the
cheek swab request form. Here's a picture of the coaching call request form to pay for it online as
well. And then we have another box on the beverage site for the cheek swab request form. So
please fill that out online. It's better. It's easier for me if you do that online. I know some people
would rather print it and send it. I guess that's okay too. Remember to always look at
the member site for any new information and like the new information company. Let's go now. We
have a subscription service if you want to subscribe and say for your supplements, you receive a
5% discount on your total order each order. Remember, again, all the courses are available to you
and remember to look at the blogs to get questions answered if you're in between weeks. Sometimes,
I had written a blog about it at some point of time. Okay, let's jump into the questions.
I had an incident happen with my right machine and I'm concerned it's been damaged in some way.
Unbeknownst to me, a toddler had been in the room where I was staying in a cabinet and unplugged
the red bulb cord. So the red cord for the bulb. I started it up that night and it was really loud.
Yes, because you're the electricity is coming out of that that outlet piece of the red cord
and it will arc to the other one. I realized the red cord had been unplugged. I absolutely
panic. I actually switched it to bat for a split second. Got a little electric shock. Then from
touching the red empty red plug in. Yes, I've actually turned down my right when I was actually
programming somebody's right. Once it never had a bulb plugged in and I got shocked but you're not
going to get electrocuted. It's not that high of a voltage coming out of that but you will get
shocked and it will scare you. I then just unplugged the power strip of the wall, turned it on
and it seemed to work fine but I'm second-guessing it. So at most in doing something like this, you will
worst-case scenario burn out the transistor on the back but really you'll blow a fuse before you do
that. So you didn't hurt your wife so don't worry. I don't remember the red on but the blinking
when there was no program running and I feel like the bulb seems dimmer. I ran the 22nd bulb check
and it lit up like it said it should. Now, how do I know if there's internal damage? If it's working,
you don't have internal damage. You didn't hurt the rife. Don't worry about it. It hurt the rife,
it wouldn't work. And then the first thing you would do is go back to the rife section on the
member site or go to the rife course and go to the troubleshooting guide and the first thing it'll
tell you to do is to check everything like that and then check the fuse. So worst-case scenario and
something like this, you would have blown the fuse. That's what a fuse is for. But you didn't blow
the fuse and it works just fine. I sent you some pictures and some lamb reports. The pictures seem
show a bit more pink around the nipple. What are your thoughts on that? So if you have any pink
this or redness of the skin or if you have good heat sensation on the back your hand, you could
actually feel for temperature changes or if you have one of those little thermometer checkers that
were popular during COVID and before that where you could check up medicines, you know,
forehead for their internal temperature. Those are actually really good little units to check
temperature on your skin. So you can check the temperature, you know, six inches away from the tumor
on the breast and then check the temperature right at the tumor and if it's increased in heat,
is that a bad thing? Well, no, that's showing that there's inflammation at the site.
Now, if you didn't have cancer and you're not trying to kill cancer cells, then you would say
that there's something going on. Let's say you got a bug bite. If you use that little thermometer
surface thermometer on a bug bite, it would show increase in temperature at the bug bite most likely
compared to two inches away from that bug bite because you have this inflammatory reaction taking
place at that bug bite because that's what a bug bite is is you have the bug that inserted
toxins into your skin into your body while it took out blood and the bug and now you have this
inflammatory response to those toxins and that's why you get this reddish or you get a raised
bump or you get itchy, you get a histamine response, etc. So is that a bad thing with cancer?
Well, no, it's not. What's where you're trying to produce is that. So just because, oh, my tumors
are more red or it's hotter, that's not really a bad thing. You're trying to get a immune response
to kill it. So I wouldn't say the color is a bad thing. Next part of the question. Last Friday,
had dark red discharge for just a little bit, but nothing says that. So a dark red discharge
wasn't blood. That's not that wouldn't be necessarily uncommon. So it's not uncommon to have that
change and have a little bleeding from the dipole or bleeding from the tumor and then it goes away.
So I wouldn't be too concerned about that. Do you have any suggestions with the thyroid
glands? I said I don't have to look at those again. The TSH, in March, was 1.81, which is fairly low.
The tree, free T4 is 0.89, which is low. And the T3 is 3.3, which is with the normal limits.
So I, you know, so remember, what you really should be receiving with the thyroid lab,
but I know this is what you got. But if you're going to ever request thyroid labs, if anybody is
going to ever request thyroid labs, if you don't get it on our site, that you do want to, you got TSH,
you got free T4 and T3. So that's free T3. You also want to get reverse T3. That tells you if your T4
is being converted to reverse T3 and issues with the gut, you want to get, make sure you get TPO
antibodies and you want to make sure you get thyroid globular antibodies and total T3 and total T4
will be the other things that would be good to get. That gives you a better picture of what's going on.
If you have elevated TPO antibodies and or thyroid antibodies, then we know that we have an autoimmune
condition going on with the thyroid and now we're dealing with Hashimoto's and that's a whole
other ball of wax. If you don't have elevated T, thyroid globular or TPO antibodies that you have
low T4 or low or I or elevated TSH, then you're concerned with just primary hypothyroidism and you
want to deal with that. Your thyroid hormones are what they're at right now and let's say you're
reverse T3, though you didn't run, let's say that's within normal limits and you have normal
limits of TPO and thyroid globular antibodies, so those are not elevated, that's pretend, since we
don't have those. And this was your readings, what you gave me. Then you're going to look at
the patient's symptoms. So what are my symptoms? Just fatigue all the time. I just don't have any
energy. I can't lose weight. I have losing my hair. I'm losing the odor one third of my eyebrows.
I just don't know what's wrong with me. Then you still want, then you want to supplement if you're
not supplemented with some thyroid stimulators. First of all, before you go to medication, you'd start
with some nutritional support of the thyroid gland, some thyroid glandulars. If I don't remember
your case, I'm sorry, who asked the question, I don't remember if you're already on medication for
your thyroid, but I would not change your medication based upon the test results. I would change
the medication or tweak the nutritional approach based upon your symptoms. Your thyroid gland, you
always want to treat your thyroid based, largely based upon your symptoms, not largely based or
primarily based upon the labs. So if you want more information on the thyroid, go to, I believe it's
module seven, six or seven on the automobile course. The entire module is dedicated to
Hashimoto's and understanding thyroid lens. In college, I said he is finding that let's
resolve, doesn't work in cancer, cancer anymore. So he's probably talking about your cancer, not
cancer in general, but yet he wants me to try it for six more weeks. Be trying this, doesn't make
sense. So, but I'm not a doctor starting to get some tingling in my back again, in my, in my back
again, like back in October, November, another node started in under the ax, auxiliary node, the
axillary node. I think he said he wants to finish a cycle and do one more and then he will look at
a different family of chemo pills in shock. I do have an update into him and we'll see what he says.
Let me know what he says. My mutation is a PIK three CA, not as common as breast cancer, not sure
if this makes a difference located to mistletoe therapy again. The tingling in your back, certainly
getting another look at that would might be a good idea. Now, your biggest side of like pathological
fracture because this person has met to the bone, biggest concern with pathological fraction,
symptom-wise, it's going to be pain. So the tingling in the back, it doesn't give me such a great
concern. There's so many other possibilities in a differential diagnosis picture to look at with that.
I do believe when I looked at your blood work, when you said to me the other day that your two
and workers were still elevated. So yeah, I would have another talk with your oncologist to see
what his plans are. Last week, I asked about why if you have cancer doing a water fast or perhaps
any kind of fastest, that's so good. I understand that you said fast, it's greater than 24 hours,
increased IGF-1 levels and increased IGF-1 levels can help cancer grow. I mentioned to
this to Dr. Goldheimer, who was the director of true to earth health, as I originally mentioned that
I understood water fasting, not to be good for cancer patients, and he was only curious why. His
response was that IGF-1 is reduced while fasting. That is generally seen as a good thing.
What is his or Dr. Cutters concerned about possible temporary transient reduction in IGF-1?
I don't know that that is his comment is true. I believe that one of the benefits of doing
longer fasts is that you do have an increase in IGF-1 and that is the benefit for people because
increase in growth factors as we age does nothing but good things unless you have cancer.
There's numerous studies where I came to the decision of the elevated IGF-1. It happens
with the fast. Let me take a step back from that comment a little bit. There's other good things
that happen with a fast. I said time and time again that I don't think it's always wise to do
greater than a 24 hour fast for a cancer patient, but it's not just because of IGF-1 levels increasing.
But it so depends on the person. Everybody's different. If you do a greater 24 hour fast,
you're definitely going to lose weight. If you have weight to lose, well then if you really feel
led to do a greater than a 24 hour fast, one day, two day, three day, week fast, we've had people do
a 21 day fast. That seems pretty hard. I've never done anything like that. But if you feel
led to do that, then by all means do it. Just make sure that you have weight that you can lose.
You don't want to push yourself in a state of caquexia because that is one of the most
difficult things for a cancer patient to get out of, is if you're in a state of tumbling weight.
Then you have to resort to not only eating more, but you have to resort to really pushing carbohydrates
because that's the only way you can really get out of caquexia. Just be careful of that.
I know that there's studies in you, you did find this meta study where IGF-1 levels
decreased with fasting. I know there's studies that will show both things. I do think that there's
other benefits of fasting. Doing a three day fast or a five day fast, there's other benefits to that.
That could maybe far outweigh any negatives that could go with a cancer patient.
I'm not against doing that. I'm just saying in general, especially if the person is kind of at
their weight or below their desired weight, doing a greater 24 hour fast, maybe contrite indicated.
If they have, I have 30 pounds and I could lose and well, then it might be a perfect thing for you
to do. If you feel led to do that, then by all means do that. Then I do want to make a point on studies.
I am big into study looking at studies, but boy, it is becoming extremely disconcerting when you're
looking at studies because there's so many contraindicative studies out there. There's one that says this
and another one that says this and it's like, what in the world are these? Why can you have all these
studies that are contradicting things? Matter of fact, somebody sent me a study on glutathione
cancer that in taking glutathione can actually help the survivability of a cancer cell. Therefore,
you shouldn't be taking glutathione. It was a problem with some of these studies, like that study,
and numerous studies that show that taking glutathione for a cancer patient helps the survivability
of a cancer cell are studies that got approved because they were doing it with chemotherapy.
I would agree that if you're taking glutathione while you're taking chemotherapy,
you're going to have a lesser chance of the chemotherapy, a.k.a an oxidized agent,
kill a cancer cell by poisoning it with an oxidized agent. If you're taking antioxidants,
so understand what glutathione is. Glutathione is your main intercellular
antioxidant. If you're taking glutathione, you're going to help with oxidizing agents that
can damage your cell and understand oxidizing agents are the number one cause of cancer. When you
say my cancer was caused from a different exposure to toxins, different exposures to heavy metals,
what are all those things? They're oxidizing agents. They damage cells. If they don't kill a cell,
well they can get it a cell and damage the DNA, thereby causing rapid replication.
Evil therapy is a poison. It's an oxidizing agent. If it doesn't kill a cell, it can actually
cause get inside of a cell and cause damage to the DNA and cause cancer. I'm not saying that
chemotherapy is necessarily the wrong thing to do. I'm just saying that just understand
where all this is coming from. From a natural perspective, natural doctors over decades have pushed
things like antioxidants, like vitamin C therapy, like glutathione, like curcumin, like nutrition that
will help support alpha-lupeic acid and things like that that will help support
oxidative stress, superoxid disputes, things like that that help support the damage of cells
from oxidative stress, which is from what's oxidative stress from. Poisons, toxins,
glutions, chemicals, additives, flavorings, colorings, heavy metals, toxins in our environment that
cause this damage to our cells that can get inside cells and remember anything like this that gets
inside the cell that can damage cells that can damage DNA, it can cause be the cause of cancer
and can kill cells. That's what a poison is. If you drink enough poison, you die. Why? Because you
have excessive oxidative stress causing cell lysis and it just destroys the person's liver and the
person dies from poison. That is just how our bodies work. So, taking antioxidants helps protect
that. The other fact is that your body actually makes glutathione, it recycles glutathione. That's how
that's why glutathione is the number one. You don't necessarily need to take glutathione. Your
glutathione is made through a cystine pathway and in glutathione is recycled inside the cell, inside
all your cells. So, even if you're not taking glutathione, you're still making glutathione,
your glutathione is trying to protect your cells. So, long story short, there's lots of studies that
will show lots of different things and you've got to take them good to learn things from it and
hang on all into citing studies and looking at studies, growing weary though in the last few years
because of so much publication bias. Publication bias is who funded the study? Well, that's the answer
that they're going to get. It's just, that's is the way it is. Now, the truth about fasting is
positives and negatives to fasting. So, you got to figure out whether positives outweigh your
negatives when you're dealing with it. That's where like any question you have with anything you're
doing, having that relationship with Jesus Christ so you could be asking Him and feeling peace about
your decision is, is one of the best ways to know which way to go forward. I've used my new
rife three nights. Tonight, the Sunday program started beeping almost like a truck going backwards.
Since this makes sleep impossible, I ran the Saturday program again. Notice a high pitch but low
volume noise from the rife as well. Is this normal? What do I do about the beeping? Unfortunately,
that is normal. It will be more at different frequencies and there's nothing that you could do
about the beeping. Now, you can use the amplifier jackhammer with it and keep the ball under the bed
and cover the rife machine up. That will help. So, most people will just get used to it and then they
just sleep through it and they doesn't cause a problem. We've had some people that had had to go to
the point to put it earplugs in but now with the jackhammer, you shouldn't have to do that. You can
cover it up and you'll still get the benefits from it. I have a magnetic pulser by SOTA. I have had my
left breast remove and had radiation and chemotherapy in 2020. Would the magnetic pulser be a good thing to
use and where should I use it? The remove breast area or on the remaining breast? Well, I'm not a good
person to ask about that. I have never used this piece of equipment and I did not have time to do any
research on it. I would talk to the manufacturer. I can't endorse it. I can't say, oh yeah,
use it because I just don't really know what it does. I'm sure it's using frequencies of some kind
and I'm sure it could be beneficial but I wish I could give you more information. A gross question
warning. Should severely itchy rectum and surrounding skin be good, severely itchy rectum and
started can be reacted to the coffee acid other in a coffee and I do them daily. I do I do have a latex
allergy. I call premiere coffee and about chronic the animal itself asking if there's latex and native
and kids and they said no. However, there was something else in their attachments that sounded questionable
but I can't think of what it was or could it be parasites. I would take advantage of this all for a while
or hemorrhoids. Typically a severe itchy rectum is not good. Well, it could be hemorrhoids probably not
though. If it's a healthy skin, it's more like a reaction to something. It certainly could be a reaction
to the coffee. Yeah, I would maybe just give it a break for a bit. Use olive oil or coconut oil on
your bottom and let that heal. I would give it a break. I don't know what your could be reacted to.
It certainly could be something in the plastic. Could be the coffee. Could it be parasites? Maybe.
The only way to know parasites, I mean technically we learned how to look for parasites. It's
severely itchy rectums. You have to put a piece taped out on your bottom and pull it off
out and then take that and put it under a microscope and look and see if there's eggs that are coming out.
But I would just honestly just give it a break for a bit. Thanks for the cheek swab results is
clear talks, a replacement for it upon one. No, it's not. So clear talks has different nutrients in it
to help pull out. I mean it was really created to help pull out MRNA and the effects of the vaccine
and the effects of COVID. So it's got a replacement for upon one. One is or phase two is really to support
the upon one pathway which is your phase two pathway in your liver. Aroboclear is that a replacement
for the clear dip? No. Clear dip has some things in it that the aroboclear has in it but aroboclear
has a greater concentration of a few things. That's why I think it tested for you.
Do you like or support the idea of you seeing the jack hammer attachment as it really amplifies
the effects? Well it does. So it amplifies the output. So it increases the strength of the
output. It doesn't change the frequency. So it increases the strength of the output thereby you could
have the bulb farther away from you. So if you're already used to having the bulb right next to you
or stuggling with the bulb there's really no need to use the amplifier personally. I don't use
the amplifier because I've been using the right for a long time and I've used to having the bulb right
next to me. So but if you were like this question previously where this noise is really bothering me
you could use the jack hammer amplifier put that on and then put it under the bed and you'll have
plenty of power amplification to go through your bed and go through you. Get the same benefit as
the bulb was made right next to you and be able to have the bulb farther away
and be able to cover it up. So you'd kind of buffle the sound and buffle the negative effects of
what you're hearing and things like that. Some people are bothered by the light. That's why we're
excited about the jack hammer and we currently include it with new rights. But most people on this
call don't have a jack hammer and because I don't think you really need one but if that is an issue
then using the jack hammer can be beneficial. You requested an update my rash and my hives this
person asked about this about six weeks ago. I still haven't know approaching seven weeks. The right
left shoulders and upper front upper chest mid to lower back other areas diminished or stocked
in general not as bad as it was in the past extremely itchy at night. I experimented a little with
stopping various protocols for a while. Didn't seem to make a difference please note that I had
break out to the past over the last few years. Never this extreme though. In the past I thought it
was a skin fungus related to nail fungus I have also usually appears as weather warms up to which
is true as this time as well. Thank you to try the rife Clark mold foot bath or Clark Kedida foot bath.
I mentioned the rife the rash to my oncologist wondering if related to the colon tumor he never
answered but suggested that they restage. He is now retired and I am getting a new oncologist with
restage next Tuesday arranged with my sister carburetor full blood panel. So I'd like to see those
results on the full blood panel. If you look at the CBC and you see an elevated eocidophil
that's a segmentation of your white blood cells. So if you have an imbalance in your white blood cells
you might have normal white blood cells come but you have elevated eocidophiles. That's a side
of allergic reaction. So you're having some sort of allergic reaction because you can have
hives in a rash and it would not be an allergic reaction. So some sort of allergic reaction and
typically you're thinking with elevated eocidophiles you're thinking of some sort of environmental
allergy like sensitivity to something that's you're wearing some chemical in the air so you know
even pollen can give you that things like that those are possibilities. It is possible that you have
rash or hives related to cancer. Typically it's lymphoma that causes rash and hives and things and
it's more so on the lower extremities maybe on the upper extremities a little bit. Most of the time
with lymphoma you'll get really really itchy. I've had people that say they found out they had
lymphoma because they're so they had such bad rash that they were scratching and they even caused
bleeding finally went in and then had some blood tests and found that it was lymphoma but it has been
noted that other cancers can cause this as well. It's not it's not completely certain why that can
happen what the issue is but it's causing some imbalance in histamine levels of the skin. Other things
that you could try are if you haven't tried like clear histamine scavenger or ABP1 assist those
products might be helpful to calm things down and over the counter at the histamine medication could help
and I actually have that information in my book. I think it's a chlamonic chlamonomy. I don't
I remember the name the brand name. It's actually an old anti histamine over the counter at the
histamine. I don't know if you can find it anymore but this it's the same metabolic pathway that
that can be an off-label use of a drug. So there were last week we talked about off-label use of
medication. Well off-label use of over the counter anti histamines can actually calm down a tumor
calm down a cancer. So I don't know maybe this is the way God's kind of pushing you to try something
like that maybe that's going to be a help with your colon cancer. You know there really isn't a whole
lot of negative side effects of over the counter anti histamines. Gosh I don't know I think I would
maybe give it a try. Maybe it's not even going to be for your rash it's going to be for your
colon cancer. So I'm gonna think about that. But do send me the results of the CBC when you get that.
I'm scheduled to receive a port tomorrow. Are there precautionary things that I should know or do?
No no it's fairly fairly safe procedure. I personally have not had experienced any one of our patients
over the 30 years plus that I've been doing this that I've had issues with their port
except if they left a port in after they discontinued chemotherapy with the understanding that
that's leave it in because we might have to do it again that you could end up with an infection
and you have to treat the infection. But that's that's something that they will go over with you
and we're long before that kind of situation. Are there things that I could do to help recover with
healing and recovery. Everything that you are doing is to be related in your response to help
your body kill cancer. You're going to help your body kill any infection. Be it in a hospital
especially current certain about infection. I will be put out and receive an antibiotic. How do I
come at the effects of the antibiotic? Using probiotics, using gut healing things like
butyric acid and butyric acid stimulating products like
indigestible fiber like sunflower or sunspectrum, curcumin to help decrease inflammation of the gut
and so the prebiotics and probiotics are what you want to go to that could help with
anybody that uses asthenes of antibiotic. Being able to use the rife while I'm using the beaver
or we'll say any PE of F device and the answer is yes so you could use those at the same time so you
could use them while you're doing it right after there's no negative effects. I've been using the
rife more during the day as well as overnight. I usually have it near or touching the tumors of my deck.
Yes I think it's best that you have the bulb as close to the lesion as possible. I've had increased
discomfort and sometimes sharp pains in the tumor during use is it's a good or bad sign. I would say
that is a good sign and I do have a video on this on the blog. It's I think it's called good pain
man pain. So you could look for that. I have some writing on that but I say that's a good sign.
I've been putting hydrogen peroxide on the open tumor on my throat. One dropper full seven
several times a day. You said hydrogen peroxide can be taken, can be toxic, take it internally. Yes it
can. Is this okay to do and how much is too much? Well it depends on what type of hydrogen peroxide
you're using. You should if you're taking something internally like that you better only be using the
3% hydrogen peroxide not the 35% hydrogen peroxide. Even at that I would attempt I would attempt to not
swallow so much of it. That can be a strong take it internally. So if you're doing a dropper full
several times a day though you're probably just fine. I wouldn't be concerned about it just make sure
it's just the 3% hydrogen peroxide not the 35%. Even the 3% hydrogen peroxide I don't think it's made
for internal use. I would be careful. I would maybe substitute hydrogen peroxide think about
substituting colloidal silver instead of the hydrogen peroxide. So colloidal silver has other
benefits that may that you could just swallow that that could be even better for you have other
brand accounts for you. Is there a brand in form of white willow bark for pain and my throat neck
that you'd recommend? Well we use the um we're inflated that I think has white willow bark in it.
There is a cytokwell from research neutrinos that I think has other it's been named cytokwell for
to quench cytokines inflammatory cytokines they're making inferreds too. So decreasing inflammatory
cytokines are inflammatory markers that I think has white willow bark and other things that we talk
about the flavonoids that we talk about but clear inflam has that in there. And even our we don't
it doesn't have white willow bark but our product called bam which is our um which we make which I
made for originally it created for a brain cancer patients and our light patients I call it bam
because it's called brain anti inflammatory mix. Not very clever if it ain't but that's what it is
so we call it bam that comes in a plastic bag um and you could mix it in your smoothie the benefit
of that is that you don't have the capsules and taking to a body capsules even a natural capsule form
could not be great for a lot of people. How long and at what temperature does a sauna provide
detoxine but not weight loss? Well a sauna is not in itself you know attempting to help with weight
loss. A person is using a sauna to sweat so you're using a sauna to sweat. Now cancer patients
will say I'm using a sauna also to try to increase my internal body temperature because if I
do increase my internal body temperature even a few degrees that can make an environment that's less
stable for cancer cells and if I die so yes so sodas are great. Sodas are one of my favorite therapies
so um no what temperature do you do it? You typically do it at 140 degrees some people do higher degrees
and you your goal is that you work towards stay in there 20 to 30 minutes. Now some people could start
with a sauna and you can only be in there for three minutes and you can't do it anymore you have to
get out personally with me with me I have a difficult time going into full body sauna I feel with my
nasal Paula issue that I feel like I have a hard time breathing that's what I like the sodas where
your head is out those are the ones that we sell and other people sell where your head is out I don't feel
claustrophobic I don't feel like I have breathing issues it increases the body temperature um it helps
we sweat just as much but I still even at that when I first started using a sauna I could only do it
for about maybe 10 minutes and I started sweating away but I'm just done pig so I guess that's easy
for me some people it takes them multiple times doing a sauna before they even start sweating
the idea of a sauna is that you're detoxing through your skin and you're taking pressure
off of your liver and the other idea is to increase your body temperature if you're fighting you're losing
weight in a sauna excuse me is you've got to be rehydrating make sure you're rehydrating you know
what you will you know when you're sweating you're you're losing electrolytes too and you don't want to
the cause dehydration I lost 20 pounds this winter from going vegan but can't put weight back on
I feel like my metabolism is on hyperdrive and then I have catexia is there a way to reverse this and
gain weight and muscle I'm sticking to the diet who gave me an eating as much and as often as possible
well the definition of catexia is that you're losing three to four pounds a week or two to four
pounds a week to let or what you're doing you're not trying to lose weight and you just can't stop
losing weight so if you're like well I'm not losing anymore weight but I can't gain it back
the question is are you under weight if yes I'm under weight I really need to gain 20 pounds back
well we do if you go to this right here and you type in catexia I have information on catexia and
some different hints that you could do and you could do that even if you don't take one out do I'd
have to catexia well who cares about the definition if you need to gain weight go back and look at
that that video on catexia and some of the hints that I give on that that will help okay and using
silver colloidal silver as a mouthwash kill the good bacteria in the mouth and got
that's a good question because you do have good microbiota in your mouth every orifice of
your body even on the outer side surface of your body you have microbiota that's the negative of
using these these you know hand cleaters that came out during COVID they're not good for you
they just disrupt your normal lora and they disrupt your microbiota even internally you absorb them
they're chemicals now you're dealing with oxidative stress from that it's just poison so I'm not in
favor of doing that and using colloidal silver or using even a regular oil in your mouth like our
tooth and gum oil with the black seed oil can you see the different mouth washes that we sell in
the store disrupt the lora the microbiota in your mouth it can you will never kill all of it but what
you're trying to do is you're trying to knock down the overgrowth of pathogenic microbiota so
um like the one the one that we have from the company biosited biosited is a great company they formulated
their mouthwash that's the one I use I think that one's the best for um dental issues
now they just came out with that last year um and they have a whole dental protocol you do it for
two months and so um but using colloidal silver I don't think you're gonna you're gonna throw off your
microbiota of the mouth I don't think so my vitamin D level is at 45 I'm trying to be in the sun as
much as possible but is there a way there's supplements to help raise my level quickly I'll be starting
chemo soon yeah we'll take you D3 is your number I mean just take you to orally and getting you know
doing um you know between five and 15,000 I use a day is the fastest way to raise vitamin D levels now
understand there are some people that they could take 20,000 I use the vitamin D a day and they just
absorb it and utilize it well because they have what are called VDR vitamin D receptor
defects on their genetic pathways and that can interrupt their ability to maintain
healthy levels of vitamin D it's probably not your case I don't remember your genetics I don't think
that's um I have had anybody with you know doubly on defects on all their VDR and
VDRQ a x genes I don't remember anybody recently that has had anything like that so just taking
vitamin D levels now vitamin D is made in the skin through seven hydroxy cholesterol um but
you know that's the that's the danger of taking statin drugs because it lowers the fat love you will
decrease your vitamin D levels in your blood by taking statin drugs because you need that
form of cholesterol in your skin in order to make vitamin D from sunlight so um
uh taking vitamin D and D3 is the one you want to take is the thing to do
I started taking five defender mushroom supplements can I have side effects from this after
started and I felt depressed instantly and felt nauseous after eating that's the only thing I did
different yeah I'm not familiar with that brand um so understand your mushroom the mushrooms that
you want to take you want them to be hot water um processed mushrooms so if they're not hot water
processed mushrooms you could be getting allergic reaction from a mushroom product um that's why
we sell our private labeled mushrooms and host defense mushrooms those are the only two
mushroom products that I really recommend um is the ones that we've created or private labeled
or the host defense brand mushrooms so I look into that on other mushroom products a lot of
their supplements out there that can um just not be good quality supplements and I've shared with
you uh multiple times as an interesting study that was done over a number of years ago now that they
took GNC target Wal-Mart um Walgreens and some other store uh supplements they took
gospel god in a bunch different supplements they tested and some had like zero of the product in it
so um second thing that can be possible is it is the capsule some people have reactions some people
have antibodies to glycerin some people have antibodies to what the capsules are made of and that could
be an issue too so those are the things that I would investigate because typically you won't get those
effects from a good quality mushroom so I think something else whenever you get chemo will my
rife programs need to be revised no we won't need to change your rife programs are there things to
do to prevent hair loss during chemo um the only thing that has been shown to prevent hair loss during
chemo is using cold um packs on your head there's actually a company that makes a a fitted like a
helmet that you is made out of that cold pack gel stuff that you put in the freezer then you put
that on your head by shilling your scalp um you can decrease the blood flow to the scalp and the
chemo is it's flowing through your blood um won't damage the um the the hair follicles because that's
what happens the chemo damages the hair follicles and your hair fall sound um now after chemo is done
usually your hair grows back in but if you could chill the hair follicles then you'll have less chance
of your hair falling out but of course you don't want your hair to fall out only in certain spots so
getting uh uh like those those helmets and you'd have to google the company that makes those we've
had a couple people that have used those um and said that they really help um and i've seen
testimonials of people that have used it and it really helped um so that is one option
i would say if you're good when you're going to do chemo you do need to go back to um the blog
and look up the chemo protocol because you do not want to be doing you know strong antioxidants
during the 48 hours after your chemo IV so let's say if you're chemo IV is at night at
pocket Monday morning you'd go off of your antioxidants for 48 hours and then you'd go back on you know
least 48 hours after that time after your let's say you finish the chemo IV at noon and Monday you
wouldn't go back on any antioxidants until noon and Wednesday at least and on that chemo protocol
do eat at 24 hour fast prior to the chemo is highly advised um and um uh their reason is if you
think of it like a cartoon cancer cells are hungry right so they're gobbling stuff up well if you do
a 24 hour fast they get super hungry and then you give chemo into the bloodstream they're going to
eat anything and the idea is if you can think of it that way now gobble up the chemo
well um there has been just time and time again of people that have done that um and the testimonials
are they have just 50% less side effects from the chemo the chemo tends to work better they have
just had better results so doing at least a 24 hour fast prior to the chemo so if you have chemo
and 9 o'clock Monday morning you stop eating at least at 9 o'clock Sunday morning um so your
cancer is super hungry and it'll gobble up the chemo and then you also go off all your antioxidants
until uh at least 48 hours after um the chemo is done uh do you recommend clear multi-bid for most people
well not everybody needs it so certainly in the summertime if you're out sweating a lot or if you're
doing sodas on a regular basis taking a mineral supplement is good if you're taking the greens
supplements and you're eating real well and you're eating where do you get your minerals from in your
diet you get your minerals from your vegetables so if you're for people who in general for people who
are like not being vegetable eaters they don't eat a lot of salads they don't like a lot of
vegetables or their idea of vegetables is corn corn is a grade not a vegetable so if that's their
idea of vegetables they're probably deficient in minerals and yes they should be taking a product
like clear multi-bid um but for even for our patients you know most of our patients are eating really
well eating better than they have in their life some of them taking the green supplement well
clear multi-bid isn't necessarily necessary for everybody so the reason why we use the clear multi-bid
is it's iron-free because why would you want to not be on iron well iron is highly inflammatory um if
you're deficient and you have anemia then you may need to be on an iron but if you're not
if you're not anemic then you shouldn't be taking iron um and you shouldn't be taking
iodine if you have any hint of any possible um Hashimoto's thyroid issues or other autoimmune
issues you want to limit your iodine levels so that's why we picked that product
my pancreatic system started at 3.5 and the second test was 4.2 just did another ultrasona was 3.2
I'm waiting on my RGCC to come back any chance my cancer markers could be increasing while the
system's decreasing or is that not enough to have a decrease to make a big deal of well I'd say I
mean I mean that's 25% decrease 4.2 to 3.2 that's a big decrease so I think that's great um
will you have a change in your tumor markers you may I mean uh again you've seen you heard from
other people that tumor markers can be fickle so a person can go on chemo that's actually shrinking
the tumor and the tumor markers actually go on because it can the cancer cells can spill more
of that protein so um you have to look at multiple markers when you look at whether a success
or failure so look at your symptoms look at how everything else is going look at tumor markers I
think it's a good thing to measure on a regular basis so you could get you know graph that out and
see the trend so that's what you want to look for doctor wants me to stay on a chemo plan for six more
weeks uh then switch to another family of chemo pills I think that one raises your insulin maybe a
phone call be easy to talk about this check it into humanizing medicine in Atlanta they would do
mistletoe uh but they are wondering if chemo may be the next step to get the tumor burned out of the
body what do you think about this um I don't think you can um you know in your state and we maybe
should do a call but I do think that I do agree with your oncologist that your body can
become kind of a viewed to a chemo after a period of time and changing up a family of drugs can be
good if you have one that raises your insulin kid conquer that with other things like burberry
so burberry can lower your insulin can lower your blood glucose level and that's how you can
you can work through it with other you know deal with it with natural methods to deal with the side
effects of a medication but not berries are good to eat when you have cancer but gerson says no to berries
what are your thoughts because I have been on a lot of berries I was uh was not listed on my list of
not to eat from you or uh or my RGCC doctor well a lot of berries can be very high in antioxidants
again so berries have a lot of good benefits to them berries also have sugar uh can raise your
glucose levels that's why getting a glucometer or just checking your glucose levels can be a good
thing to do you could go to target or Walgreens or something like that and buy a glucometer for a really
cheap you always want to check that in a fasting state now on the member site I actually have a
form you can download to measure your glucose on a regular basis you always want to do that in a
fasting state so typically you do that when you wake up in the morning uh you measure your glucose
the goal is really to get your glucose around 75 80 that's really what you want to do
um and if berries are spiked eat it so again so there's I mean there's a we could talk an hour
about this because because some people can eat some carbohydrates and it really does very little to
their blood glucose some people can eat just a little bit of carbohydrates and their blood glucose
just spikes through the roof why is that because it's it's has to do with how damaged your cells
are the the insulin receptors on your cells so um your glucose level has a lot to do with your diet
but it has even more to do with the health of your cells your cell membranes in particular
also the health of your paecrease itself because your paecrease part of your paecrease makes insulin
but if a person let's say doesn't have an issue with that part of the paecrease they do not have
type well diabetes which is an autoimmune disease on the on the cells in the paecrease the
paecrease they make insulin they say they do not have that and they have issues of getting their
glucose levels down then it's really a cell membrane issue i just talked to somebody the other day
that said that they eat really super healthy and they actually went on a keto diet and they were
doing really good on their keto diet they did it for three months they did really well they went
off their keto diet and they're still eating super super clean this is actually a fairly young person
but they noticed that their glucose levels spiked and i said well what an ant she said i can't
really get them down now it's been months what an ant they're in the two hundreds range only come
that's not good so i said you immediately have to get in and get checked my suspect is that this
that a ketogenic diet actually sparked an autoimmune attack on the on the paecrease this person
is type one diabetes now i don't think it's type two diabetes i think it's type one so the
difference between type one diabetes and type two is type one as an autoimmune disease on the paecrease
type two is just damaged cell receptor sites and so totally different it should be called something
different but both result in elevated glucose levels so maybe too much information but it really
depends on your glucose levels ultimately but in general i disagree with Max Gerson i think that
berries have much benefit now if you're drinking juice like like grape juice or
raspberry juice i don't know there is raspberry juice but that is that is you're just getting the sugar
you're not really getting the benefit if you eat the whole food it's huge benefits of the whole food
and the synergistic you know nutrients that are in that food that we haven't even discovered yet
so eating the whole berries has lots of benefits but to really make sure getting a glucose
check your glucose would be the way to go should all rife programs have allowed noise as i don't hear
anything except a very low pitch sometimes correct a lot of right it's been to the frequency that
you're ready the lot of the lower frequencies for different types of cancer could have a
longer noise some don't have anything i don't ever hear anything with my right but i guess i
take that back at different times they wake up at different times to go to the bathroom or something
that it's like lemon rife is noisy what's because i never heard it before because i was sleepy but
it's happened to wake up at this time and that's probably one of the never one questions that we get
all my gosh i woke up to go to the bathroom when my rife was just like making this really long
noise is there something wrong with that it's never happened like this before will you probably never
woke up on that particular night never every one of your nights are different and so they're ready
different frequencies at different times you never woke up at Monday night at two o'clock to go to the
bathroom to hear that and you actually went to bed at the exact same time so you're ready to add
exact frequency at that time so different frequencies will cause more noise i plan on using the
curcuclear soon for curcumin before joining the clinic i had a large supply of terry naturals
curcumin 750 milligrams is this brand good to use up for now as i still have two months left
i would say yeah i mean i get the waste supplements um
most of the curcumin supplements out there are are fun most of it's the it's the minerals that
a lot of the mineral supplements are garbage a lot of the mushroom supplements are garbage a lot of
herbal supplements are garbage you're fine with curcumin though uh what is your thoughts on
and medium roast coffee versus golden color light roast coffee so the the light roast coffee that we use
is specifically for coffee animals so if you bought it from us it's coffee and i'm a coffee if you
try to drink it you would be able to drink it it's just you you get sick so it is got much higher
caffeine to stimulate your parasympathetics um and that's what you're trying to do is stimulate
your bagelder with the coffee animals now again using any coffee uh let's say i don't have that
can i just use any coffee yeah you can but the light roast coffee is just it's just better
this gluten away a good supplement to reduce gluten so these i don't familiar with gluten away
but these products like that these uh these gluten and dairy reducing supplements they're not
to reduce gluten there if you if you're going if you're on a gluten-free diet or a dairy-free diet
and you're eating out and they tell you it's gluten-free but you're afraid that you could get
cross-contamination and you're trying to reduce it these are enzymes so these products like gluten
away or gluten-zyme or gluten-zyme is the us enzyme one we have three or four different
brands that have it all they are is gluten enzymes they're enzymes that will help write down gluten
doesn't give you a cart plunge to eat gluten then you take one of these and it's going to be okay
no it doesn't work that way do any of these type of supplements rid your body of excess gluten
no none of them do so it's just going to help reduce breakdown any hidden gluten that you might have
got from eating that meal so um we have we have multiple of these um um orthomolecular
we can be kidding orthomolecular on our site anymore they have a dg umzyme or something like that
for dairy gluten it's enzymes for dairy gluten uh us enzymes has a glue design um that's a real good one
apex has one there's multiple uh the science for health has uh has an allure enzyme that's got
there is enzyme for dairy and gluten also is lacto a fair and good for anemia in uh live phoma with
low blood counts um i don't know i'd have to research that i'm sorry i don't know the answer to that
one so can i try two different programs on my rife on the same day you can run a different program
every hour on your rife on the same day you can use it you can use it all day long and yes you can do
whatever you want so you can't overdo that unless you're doing kill programs like Lyme disease kill
programs um you can overdo that because um like a polysaccharides in a gram negative bacteria now that
tumors have been removed is the armpit the best place to place the rife bulb at night or the liver
uh it's still going to go through you either way you can lay by your side either way it's going to
be penetrating you so it's not really that important if it's the area only food grade hydroproxide is
for internal use one drop times three a day still it's 35 percent so i would be careful of that
i would agree on that with this the three percent over the counter it's a really it's not for
internal use so i would not be using that i'm sure probably it would hurt you but i still wouldn't use
it i'm an alternating hydro peroxide colloidal silver and tumor tincture each hour on the open tumor
in my throat but if it's internal in your throat thereby you're swallowing it i would i would not use
the hydro peroxide um following up on the itching rash i caught a cold a few days ago and i had a
hundred degree fever on Monday what was surprising is that my fever all itching went away completely
at least for a day any ideas oh wow i got to think about that a little bit so having a fever decreased
i have to think about that a little bit why would it fever have decreased
unless a fever increases increases your um d a o and z that's it would be my thought
fever made decrease or may increase the production of the d a o enzyme which
is made through genetic pathway or htm pathway um how you get rid of inflammation histamines
um it has to be like cytokines in the tissues and in the skin so i bet you a fever increases the
production of d a o enzyme up to research i thank you for that observation i heard that a sauna
what temperature 104 140 140 degrees do you have a d3 you recommend yes that adk avail adk complete
so that's what we would recommend we look and see if i have you on that
will the rife program for candida be enough to get rid of overgrowth
we've had people get really good results with the rife and using it for candida and other
a guy and and um molds and infections and biotoxins will that be enough i don't know
the benefit of using it first is that you're not you're not going to you're not adding chemistry
to the body so with your using like uh uva uva herb at your using burba read at your using um different
herbals to kill um a pathogen like that you're changing body chemistry which is fine but a lot of
people are on a lot of things already and you don't want to be on anymore stuff that's why i always say
use the rife as your first go to to try to kill it uh you can't do wrong with it um i would definitely
give it a good go and then if you're apt to add my coolant seed oil or something like that to it to
maybe you could do one at a time to see how you could do that. Dina you asked about the d3 supplement
i looked at you said you had metagenics d3 10,000 plus k you still have that take that
so that's a good supplement take that one if you don't have any of that anymore um then
um i don't i didn't so i didn't say stop on that once i assume that you were still taking that one
so if you're not then let us know i'll let you get you know what to take uh i ate the gursan musili
for several months every day it was not curative as the tumors continue to grow however would it still
be good to continue i don't remember what that is i haven't looked at that for years i'm sure it's fine
it is carbohydrates but i'm sure it's fine as long as the ingredients don't go against what we told
you to can two of our cars increase because of pathogens well i i don't know i've never heard that
to be the case i wouldn't think so so i wouldn't think so my glucose was 87 but my A1c was for
5.4 which is not elevated but it's kept up there should my A1c be lower
that you know this is where you know dealing with blood glucose isn't as simple as i'm going to go on a
diet not eat sugar in my blood glucose it's going to go down my he will go with A1c it might be elevated
that's a better indication of how you're processing uh gluten to oh the musili is kind of cheese but so
it's that um butaway protocol um i don't know dairy was your was a driver i think dairy was a
driver so i said no to it so i would say no to that uh so glucose at 87 is not too high but what you're
dealing with cancer and if you had what you don't if you had a really active cancer that you're
trying to deal with you really want your glucose to be lower than that but in your case your cancer
is in pretty much a state of remission so um do you need to work actively to lower it not
necessarily if there are other things that you could do to help decrease your hemoglobin A1c
yes from a nutritional standpoint my first thought is burburied um chromium can help with that true to
um so um and then look at your diet if you're you're probably really clean i don't eat a lot of sugar
and ODA and that stuff but i wouldn't worry about it too much um if you have burburied if you have
picolidate chromium picolidate at home you can start taking some of that and see how that could help
with your cell membranes okay we've got a long time i think we will call it for the day um thanks
for getting your questions in trying to make every effort to get them in as soon as you can um
otherwise i may not get them on the call though that i'm praying for all of you and i will see you next
week and call me if you need to chat with me bye bye